in the last few videos we wrote a nice
little program here that asks the user
for some type of an input and then
computes the factorial of that number
and then prints it out and that's nice
but you could imagine a world where you
would want to calculate the factorial
multiple places or in multiple different
programs or in the same program you want
to calculate the factorial multiple
times and you don't want to have to
write this code over and over again
every time you want to calculate a
factorial so what i'm going to do in
this video is define a function that
calculates the factorial and then we can
use that function every time we want to
calculate the factorial so essentially
what that function is going to do is
going to put all this code all of this
code right here in one place and then
any other program that i want to
calculate the factorial i can just
recall that code i don't have to rewrite
it so let me just show you what i'm
talking about so i'm going to define a
function and the keyword in python so
it's kind of a special word word that
tells the interpreter that something
special is about to happen the key word
in python for defining a function is def
so i'm going to define a function i'm
going to call it the factorial function
and it's all it tends to be a good idea
to name things indicative of what they
actually do sometimes
beginning programmers have a habit of
naming things like x425 and someone who
comes in later will have no clue of what
that variable or that function is all
about so you definitely want to somehow
name it so it gives an idea of what it's
supposed to do
my my function is called factorial and
the user when they when they call
factorial they need to tell factorial
what number do i am i going to take the
factorial of so they're going to pass it
an argument called number and if these
words make a little look a little
confusing i'll explain them in detail in
a second but you can just hopefully the
more you see this the more you'll
familiar the more familiar you'll be
you'll get with these ideas
and so they're going to pass it number
and i'm just going to have to return
back to the to the calling program and i
actually shouldn't even say the user is
going to pass a number the calling
program is going to pass a number and i
need to return back the factorial of
that number to the calling program so
let me write this down as a comment
actually
so
number
so returns
the factorial
of
the argument
of the argument number and sometimes
you'll hear the word parameter sometimes
you'll hear the word argument when
you're making a definition of a function
this is more formally called a parameter
number is one of the parameters to the
the func to the to the factorial
function the actual number that someone
else
passes to it so let's say someone calls
factorial with a 3 here then more
formally that 3 would be the argument so
it returns the factorial of the argument
number and this is the argument number
right over here so i literally mean i
don't mean this is just like arbitrarily
the word number i'm literally talking
about this number right over here maybe
i'll say the argument
the argument number maybe i'll put in
quotes to make it clear that this is the
argument i'm not talking about any
general number let's define it
so we're going to use the same the same
code essentially actually let me just
copy and paste let me just copy and
paste a lot of what i took over here so
i'm going to cut that out and i'm going
to repaste it over here but i have to be
careful about my indentations because
indentations are how python knows what's
part of what it knows how to interpret
things so everything that's part of this
function definition has to be indented
and we do it by four spaces one two
three four
then this is another four two
4 and then this is part of the for loop
1 2 3 4. and let's think about what we
have so far so it's going to be past
some number
we define this variable product equals 1
and we'll talk more about scoping of
variables but this variable is only
going to be usable within this factorial
definition because the first time i
define it right here is inside of this
right here so we'll we'll go more into
scoping of variables in the future and
then we're the same logic we did before
for i in range of number now we're not
getting number using the input function
it's just being passed to the it's being
passed to the function
then product is equal to product times i
plus 1. same logic as we had before so
after you go through this for loop
after you go through it you're
essentially going to go through it
number times
product will have in it the factorial of
number instead of outputting it directly
what we want to do is return we're going
to return it to the calling program in
the next video i'm going to diagram this
out a little bit cleaner if this seems a
little bit confusing to you i'm going to
return product so it's essentially the
exact same code as we had before but
we've packaged it inside of a function
we've defined a function takes in it has
a parameter called a number if you pass
factorial if you want a factorial of
three you'd write factorial of three and
three would be the argument the thing
that's being put in the place of the
variable number or the thing that number
is referring to you define product is
equal to one
and then you go you go number time so
for i in range of number we explained
the logic of that in the previous video
every time you start with one and then
you do one times one it's going to be
one and then product is going to be one
but then i is going to be 1. i starts
off at 0 so it's going to be 1 times 0
plus 1 gives you 1. then i is 2 so it's
going to be 1 times 1 sorry then i is 1
and so it's going to be 1 times 1 plus 1
which is 1 times 2 so it's going to be 2
then and it'll keep incrementing that
way and we explained that in detail in
the last video and then finally it's
going to return that product so if we
want
to have the same exact behavior as
before but now we're using this function
what we could do is
we could say we'll still have the input
so this is our function definition but
then along our main program we've
defined our function and now we can just
say look from the user get a
non-negative integer to take the
factorial of and let's put that into
let's call that a variable called user
input
user input
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to define another variable to
called factorial of
user input
factorial of user input and now this is
going to be interesting i'm going to
call this function up here so this is
going to be equal to factorial of
whatever the user had input so the
factorial of user
input the factorial of this variable
right over here the factorial of user
input so now factorial of user input
will be storing or i guess we should say
it'll be pointing to the actual answer
and now we just have to print it out
so now we can print
now we can print factorial
of user input so these are just they
look like sentences but these are just
variable names and i'm naming this way
so you really know what's inside of
those variables or what those variables
are really pointing to so factorial of
user input
now
you know the you always the the the
moment of truth is always saving the
program and actually trying to run it so
let's try to run it right now and see
what happens
let's see what happens here
so
at least nothing broke so far so once
again so i want to be clear the program
started here but up here all we did is
define this so it's not actually telling
it's not it's not creating any
interaction with the user it's actually
not processing anything just yet so it
just defines this function then it goes
down to here and it says okay look get
some input from the user and that's what
we are we're doing right here and after
we input some number here then it's
going to go it's going to actually call
this function with that number that we
put the number that we put is going to
go put in the user input and then it's
going to call factorial with user input
as an argument so let's try it with the
number three
so let's try it with the number three
and it did not work it did not work oh
and i see why it did not work because i
had this leftover from the previous
program which actually makes no sense
now so let me get rid of that
it's a good lesson that seldom on the
first try does something work perfectly
let me try it again let me try again
that was just nonsense that i didn't
even realize was down there so let me
try it again
so let me try so three again
and it gave me it gave me a good answer
it gave me the factorial 3. and what's
cool now is because now my python
interpreter is assuming that this
definition has been made i can now call
the factorial straight from the
interpreter if i had another program i
could call it multiple ways and now you
should hopefully appreciate why it's
cool that we made this function
definition because now we can calculate
because i have defined this function
factorial i can calculate the factorial
of 4. it's 24. i could say the factorial
of
of 5
the factorial of 5 minus the factorial
minus the factorial of 3.
114 i can take the factorial of 12. and
you can tell the computer even though
this is just interpreting all of this
we'll talk more about interpreted versus
compile code it's incredibly fast faster
than we can really even fathom
so so this is the real power of a
function is that i don't have to rewrite
the code every time now i can just call
it with different arguments so factorial
of two i can do it every time i don't
have to rerun the program
if i write other programs that use
factorial maybe i do some things in
combinatorics i can just use this as a
function in fact i don't even have to
know what's going on beneath beneath the
beneath what's going on inside the
function that's another powerful
i guess util one of one of the other
powerful aspects of functions is that
let's say i write a bunch of programs
that call so i have this program right
here that calls factorial but let's say
that you come up with a better way of
writing this right over here as long as
your program that has the same gut that
does the same thing with different guts
the end user won't notice so maybe you
write a faster way or a simpler way of
doing this a way that uses less memory
or less cpu power then you could just
replace this later on and then the any
program that calls it as long as it
still works it'll work for that program
it'll just work that much better